warning spoilers dead ahead what's going
on guys
Kong Skull Island proved to be the king
of the box office this past weekend but
is the movie great isn't even good well
today we're setting out to solve that
debate and we have two men who often
work together on opposing sides of the
argument first you know him as the host
of Dan's labyrinth on screen junkies
plus he's the movie fights champion dan
Merle pleasure to be here how and making
a rare appearance on screen junkies he's
the creator of honest trailers and the
host of movie fights
Andy signor Andy I'm happy to be here
speaking of movie fights this episode
three years ago does Godzilla suck was
the first official movie fight done here
on this set and who knew it would have
spawned a champion a whole show and a
whole xialu of questions and argument
wow that's a cool piece of nostalgia Dan
yeah what side of the argument are you
on today this is gonna surprise a lot of
people considering particularly my past
with Andy but I'm on the side that Kong
Skull Island was an enjoyable film Andy
what side of the debate are you on Kong
Skull Island sucked it was a huge
disappointment
I'd like to parts of Kong but as a movie
as a whole does not hold up gotcha
let's get this started dan what did you
like
why was Kong Skull Island a very
enjoyable movie going experience
important thing to remember here is that
not every movie is created equal you
have to look at each movie and say did
this movie set out did it succeed and
what it's set out to do and I contend
that Kong sky land did succeed in what
it set out to do it was a b-movie it was
very much a product of its creature
feature roots it set out to establish
Kong it set out to establish the world
that Kong inhabits crazy monsters it
could have used a little more character
development I'll be the first one to
admit that but it was a movie that set
out to be a romp through a crazy jungle
with crazy animals it succeeded in doing
that and because of that I'm gonna say
that it is an enjoyable film boom
opening salvo Andy signor give us your
opening statements look he gives us he
says it's a B film and if I want to be
film that
want to have these weird bad characters
that are taking me out of the monster
nonsense this film was filled with
countless minutes of useless human
beings that had no right to be there I
did care about Kong I actually enjoyed
the appearance of Kong when he took down
those helicopters but then what happens
they just fall into all of the boring
generic tropes of that these
blockbusters have reason to do where
instead of these these interesting
people scattered throughout an island in
this amazing b-movie Island they
immediately just go into two groups in
all of the fun b-movie tropes and sort
of thought things I thought we were
gonna go we're just completely wasted
see I thought that the whole movie they
were having fun was it that's what made
me enjoy the film was a simple story
doesn't mean a bad story stories can be
simple and still be enjoyable Tom
Hiddleston and brie Larson the two lead
characters I agree not enough to do but
I think that was bailed out by the fact
that Sam Jackson at least they made his
character simple and easy to understand
Kong's old my soldiers I want to kill
Kong okay that's motivation and that's
what he does in the movie you don't have
to question what he's doing he doesn't
do about it in a convoluted way he says
I hate that monkey and I'm gonna go kill
it
secondly john c reilly by far the best
person in this movie I agree the Tom the
Tom Hiddleston and brie Larson storyline
would have fallen completely flat if not
for the fact that they did meet john c
reilly john c reilly i thought was funny
i think he improvised most of his
dialogue which I think was why it was
better than almost anything else in the
fellas steve brule himself he for all
himself and it gave that side of the
story and injection of humor and an
injection of fun that it needed is this
completely different movie he's in the
reason he's funny is because it felt
like well crap he needs to explain
everything it's happening so let's go
ahead be funny cuz we need something to
happen here and that to me stinks of a
bad movie of he has to come in and save
moments that again I got a harp on
Huddleston and brie Larson this was a
sign where I'm like is brie Larson as
good as we think she is like what on
earth choices is she make I get a
director tells you what to do but come
on girl you're a photographer you're a
war photographer on a brand new island
and all these things take some damn
photos she took no she did not she
hardly took a single away the movies
Mandelson doing this on the boat yeah
like that I wasn't I was so offended by
the waste of these on me I think
fantastic actors aimless nursing there
do nothing so yes john c reilly shows up
and just something yes but it didn't
make any sense yes we're there we didn't
I'll throw this out there to both of you
were there too many characters to follow
yes John Goodman complete waste he has
to sit on luggage at one point to tell
you what's happening and then the whole
sort of build-up of his characters gonna
prove right you don't even get to have
that moment with him he doesn't really
even get to experience it all of the
countless soldiers that really should
have could have had a few R if they just
Whittle it down had a good couple good
stories I can't tell you who the hell
was what and did what one guy as a kid
okay he's gonna die clearly it just they
were so paint-by-numbers generic soldier
well the guy was the kid first of all
they at least subverted that cliche as
far as like the guy that you're rescuing
he's out but they got it then Samuel
Jackson has given the dog tags he's
still dead no no I'm gonna take my men
in and we're still going to get after
this buddy that was that mix the story
up because even when you confront him
with the fact that he's on a task that
even underscores how even crazier that
the guy is it's like he's literally now
doing this to Morty no reason exactly
too crazy for me to enjoy it I see I
just some people's laughing right
because he has blood lust for war I
disagree because what this movie is
about at its core is Kong and is about
the creatures that are on this island
and I liked the way that they set these
people up in scenarios to showcases that
yes the human characters could have used
improvement but they're not the focus of
the story the focus of the story is the
crazy creatures and the fights and those
were done exceptionally let's focus on
that focus on that for a moment Andy was
there enough action for you in this
movie Kong has some good moments yes and
a Kong itself I thought was a good
character but he's ruined to me by
Samuel Jackson's sort of I'm a bad guy
is so overly generic bad guy that just
made no sense to me so yes that
distracted me because who does Khan
really go up against he goes up against
these skull creatures that are kind of
cool but that's all it was like I can't
just have a movie with just that it's
just it all it all is very reminiscent
to me of a similar debate we had about
Jurassic world which is hilarious to me
well maybe you're saying these things
Jurassic world is the B movie that I was
are doing this movie took itself too
seriously no it went and what didn't go
over that edge where I thought drastic
world did of crazy training Raptors Dino
DNA like that's what made drastic world
fun see I disagree with you
fundamentally because the hallmark of
the B movie the B movie that this movie
was is that the movie and the characters
in this movie always take things more
seriously than the movie takes itself
and that's the thing that I thought they
did figure out in this movie that they
didn't figure out address of world what
Jurassic world it was how about the
dinosaurs and the eighteen plotlines the
kids parents getting divorced and no it
didn't have a flatline I have two
minutes characters I'll agree with you
but it had two major it had two plot
lines really these people want to leave
these people want to fight Kong and
that's it and that's monarchy
Riley's holistic world had fifteen
different plot lines about weaponized
Raptors and every other thing understood
that nobody cares about it was so
convoluted it was so much exposition and
talking talking talking talking talking
talking where john c reilly just plows
exact exposition as a whole twice
explain why this movie what's ten times
what it was no way i know any one of
those confines dark greasy can't even
see what's going on you can't even tell
case so are you saying that here X and
Raptor helper yeah boss look I've
stepped back from Jurassic world I'm not
as such people are gonna say oh you've
dressed world is stupid it is stupid I
want to put on record
I had fun in the theater I turned my
brain off and I'd fun I couldn't do that
I was I went to go do that in this movie
and I couldn't because it was the tones
were too mixed I don't want to
relitigate this entire Jurassic world
debate oh it's up for debate now sir
we're here today talking Kong Skull
Island it's very similar Dan was the
action satisfying and do you feel like
it heightened properly for you the
action was immensely satisfying
even the biggest detractor of this movie
will tell you that the action is what
kept it afloat even if they didn't like
anything else in this movie the first
Kong scene where he's taking down the
helicopters is and I will say this right
see best Kong sequence I have seen in a
King Kong movie good scene bar none now
if it had all gone downhill from there I
could see people's points but it does
the scene at the end where Kong is
fighting the big skull crawler that is a
great monster on monster sequence and
had a great capper to it it had the
thing where it comes back and I love
that I thought that was great and then
in the middle what I loved was that they
didn't just rely on Kong to do all this
stuff
they had inventive creatures that had
inventive ways to stage the action and
ultimately I think that's what makes it
an enjoyable film is it's not perfect
it's not but it knows what movie it is
it stays focused on that and it delivers
on what you want to see when you're
going to see that movie this one I just
thought took itself too seriously and
then fine if you're gonna do that give
me good characters then I can't take you
seriously if you have give me bad
characters that moment with brie Larson
is so forced
there's a really cool shot where she's
on his hand it looked fantastic I
thought that was a really cool moment
but come on there have been so many good
women who have acted opposed King Kong
from Naomi Watts to just playing so many
actors have had those words and I didn't
buy it for a second with brie Larson I'm
glad that they didn't go with the whole
Larson she's my pet now but they didn't
he saved her at the end but there wasn't
the whole love story there wasn't 30
minutes of him carrying her around and
adopting her okay um there's been a lot
of debate back and forth I'd like to get
a couple of bullet point moments from
each of you that really typify your
argument Andy let's start with you what
were the moments specifically that
undermine that dragged down this movie
for you I mean to me the ending didn't
help at all like there's a good monster
finale moment but then they suddenly
miraculously get off this really hard to
get on island that we've established is
hard and then suddenly they get out
peacefully and then they're locked in
this room in the Africa it seemed to
sort of set up the tone of there's more
islands to go to with brie Larson and
Tom Hiddleston mind you I was just like
oh really so we have this core group of
boring people they couldn't focus on the
other characters they were so stuck on
the monsters which they did okay on but
I need more
and that for my monster movie I want
some characters to care about when they
die or do I not want them to die or a
villain that I'm sort of I see as flawed
I didn't get any of that in this movie
dan what are some moments some things
that made the movie work for you you go
to the movies for different reasons and
I think that a lot of it depends on how
a movie decides it's going to approach
it I think that Jordan vogt-roberts and
everyone involved with the movie said we
are gonna kind of do this this this
return to this 50s sci-fi be feel of a
military goes to that an island and
finds a bunch of monsters and we're
gonna see how creative we can be with
that and I think they did it in a really
fun in a really different way plus the
addition of a really great character in
Kong plus a lot of great Kong scenes a
lot of great monster fights and some
interesting human characters did it do
enough to be enjoyable they do enough
for me to come out of that movie saying
like you know what I had a really great
time I had some laughs I jumped a lot I
saw some cool stuff you know what I did
and that's why I'm saying this was a
movie that I like it's gotcha gentlemen
shake hands always fun to argue with mr.
Murrell passionate arguments loud
arguments gentlemen I felt like I was in
the middle of a kaiju battle well done
uh what did you think
did Kong Skull Island rule did it suck
was it somewhere in between let us know
in the comment section below we want to
know and which one of these dudes won
this debate tell us that too I want to
thank Dan Merle my pleasure house always
good to talk to you buddy
and Andy signor thanks for coming in
thank you guys and I want to thank you
for watching I'm howling it hit me up on
Twitter bye bye hey guys did you know
that this end card works with your phone
now I know right click the boxes below
to watch more screen junkies videos and
click the screen junkies logo to
subscribe and get this show honest
trailers movie fights and more